hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm Monster Hunter world
against here to be talking about how to
get the nuage or star blade except it's
not really too new it is part of the usj
type of armour said that's only in Japan
except now some of the Western hunters
can now get it but we'll get into that a
little bit later but as always like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
cover the solo guides a Monster Hunter
world that being the higher up monsters
tips and tricks to make everyone a
better monster on our player and the
event quest every week so that everybody
knows what's in those event quest what's
new and what comes with it so with that
let's get started so to get this weapon
you need to be doing the quest usj gold
star treatment to get the eyes or palico
armor in the low rank our star blade in
this quest you fight three jaggers's at
once one large one medium and one very
tiny small one this quest wasn't
originally for everyone only the
Japanese monster hunter accounts were
only available to get this but now
everyone is available to get this except
so far we only have the first part at
low rank so maybe in the future we'll
get the high rank set but once done you
will get the ash or star shards which
are necessary to craft the armor but the
Asura blade in terms of stats does 363
rod damage 20 affinity 121 water damage
and green sharpness so overall not too
bad in low rank but honestly really not
that great obviously since it is only
rarity 3 and it's a low rank weapon
we'll have to wait for the high rank
weapon to make a better judgment on the
weapon if it's good or not yeah guys
it's going to be a really quick video on
how to get the azure star blade weapon
in the ABS or pellicle armor of course
it's like the V if you did enjoy
subscribe if you're new like I said I
covered the solo guides of most of the
monsters in monster honor world tips and
tricks that I ever won a better Monster
Hunter player and the event cost every
weeks that everyone knows which ones are
new and what info you can get out of
those and more rewards and stuff like
that way to most abusive videos would be
on screen if you guys want to check that
out with that guys so ever yesterday and
you guys for watching the video and
peace out